we asked ourselves what if we lined up
some of the world's top minds in science
astronomy technology academia and
futurism and got them to ponder some of
the most popular what-ifs this is what
if discussed here are Teddy Wilson and
Richard Garner
welcome to what if discussed
specifically the beginning of what if
discussed our first ever episode I'm
Teddy Wilson and I'm Richard garner
today's episode and question is what if
we lived in a galactic Zoo Richard have
you pondered this question in your life
a lot today today we're gonna ponder the
heck out of it I've pondered it to be
honest the the first time I saw the the
what if video what if we lived in a
galactic Zoo I had not ever put those
two words together galactic and Zoo you
not so so I had not pondered living in a
galactic Zoo I had but however I'd
pondered the idea of it the you know I
mean we've seen it a lot in a whole
bunch of different sci-fi treatments
about yeah this idea that we're either
animes or an experiment or in a zoo or
whatever it is not knowingly and then of
course there's somebody sort of Truman's
show style on the other side of that
watching us or observing us so but the
interesting thing about the zoo part is
it it implies that right it implies a
few things that we know from animal zoos
it means we sort of went out and hunted
some I don't know creature species cage
them put them into some facility so we
could kind of a scientifically observe
them but be from a society standpoint
just go and get you know eat some
popcorn and watch the gorillas and the
Zebras and if that's the case and if
we're in a quote-unquote Galactic Zoo
obviously in this analogy we're the
Zebras and where are the Apes and I
don't know how well that sits with most
people right now it's certainly humbling
yes it's certainly humble it should be
humbling well it's interesting because
to me the notion of
you know could we be in a collective zoo
or that question rather is has a couple
different prongs one of those prongs or
one of the possibilities could be that
we were actively put in the zoo put in
some sort of pen or cage that cage of
course being earth or maybe being our
solar system or maybe being the Milky
Way galaxy who knows but that's one
possibility
another possibility is less than where
we were put in this position or in this
reality by an alien race by some sort of
super being and rather we are being
observed by an alien race or a super
being but we weren't necessarily put
here and that that kind of lesser idea
that we are just being observed as
animals in a zoo are goes way back in
science fiction so does the notion that
we were put here but for me I was first
attracted to this idea and first started
to really contemplate this idea that we
could be being watched
specifically by aliens I was first
turned on to that by arthur c clarke
childhoods end of course arthur c clarke
one of the great sci-fi authors of all
time you mentioned them in the same
breath as Isaac Asimov or Ray Bradbury
Ursula K Le Guin and of course others
and childhoods end posits the question
what if we were being watched and what
if that alien race one day revealed
itself to us in childhoods end I won't
get into spoilers but the alien race
reveals themselves when were on the
verge of spaceflight that's a very
similar plot point that we saw in Star
Trek first contact where aliens in that
case it was Vulcans revealed themselves
the first time we used warp drive so
there's usually something that prompts
our galactic zookeepers to reveal
themselves and sometimes it turns out
well sometimes it doesn't but certainly
it's a well-worn trope within sci-fi and
I've actually been thinking about this
question since I was a teenager and I
find it and lessly intriguing and I do
too in terms of the like again the zoo
thing not so much I hadn't necessarily
thought of it from that because again
there's there's a there's another level
of implication of what being the zoo
from our experience here on earth
implies but the idea being observed
let's say this is what I would have used
I would have used the wordix
oh right for me that that's been
something I've thought about for for a
long time and again partially because
you're you're kind of steered towards
that through some of the great sci-fi
and and literature that you do read or
watch growing up of course movies like
The Matrix was a you know for a lot of
people was like a massive awakening to
even the idea of and you know that gets
into a whole bunch of other areas but
just the overall idea that you know and
you use the word humbling when you get
outside of the idea that we are at the
you know a we're all that there is be
that we human beings are with
undoubtedly at the top of the food chain
and then you start to to postulate the
ideas of both those things not being the
case well it changes your entire
perspective on things and that obviously
brings into what you were talking about
is it aliens is super beings is it us
from the future watching us you know
what I mean is it god what is it if god
and that's and that's probably as old as
the question of god yeah yeah what I
mean I mentioned a few examples of this
being tackled in fiction South Park also
kind of addressed if it's 2002 episode
felt canceled it's been represented in
video games will write who of course
famously created the Sims and SimCity
did a very well on video game called
Spore which kind of looked at this
question as well so it's well
represented in fiction and it's also
well represented in terms of real-world
thinkers and we're gonna have one of
them on the show later and he is
probably one of the only people on earth
who could say that they have an informed
opinion on this matter because he's been
at the top of the pyramid in the search
for alien intelligence for decades
Douglas vac odds will be joining us
later in the show but first let's take a
closer look at what if we lived in a
galactic Zoo imagine being trapped in a
zoo well if we really do live in a
galactic Zoo then you'd already be in
one a lien could be out there watching
your every move they may want to study
the human race or learn from our
technology or maybe they're planning to
attack us but are we sure that
intelligent life is even out there
well the odds are pretty good the
existence of alien life could be
explained by the Fermi paradox we have
our Sun but in the universe there are
billions of other Suns
and they're billions of years older than
our solar system orbiting these other
Suns could be earth-like planets and on
earth-like planets there's a good chance
of there being highly intelligent life
with so many worlds out there there's an
even better chance that at least one of
them has developed interstellar travel
the Fermi paradox suggests that with
interstellar travel it would take a few
million years to travel through the
entire Milky Way galaxy you may think
that sounds like an incredibly long time
but if there's a civilization that is
billions of years older than us it would
just be a tiny fraction of their history
so if all this is true which is very
likely the aliens may have already found
us and apart from us being a pretty
violent species we may not be
interesting enough for them to make
contact with us we may just be another
life-form out of the thousands or
millions that the aliens have seen after
all if you see an ant colony on the
ground do you try to make contact with
it you most likely go along with your
day to other life-forms out there we may
just be a simple group of ants ants they
don't want to hurt or bother just
observe another thing we have to keep in
mind is how we communicate with the
aliens ants in our world might be trying
to communicate with us but unless they
send the right signals we'll never know
the same goes for the aliens and us we
may not be communicating with the aliens
the right way they may not even know
that we want to make contact with them
so they just leave us alone
what is the best way to communicate with
aliens we'll leave that story for
another what-if well to paraphrase a
well-worn trope I for one welcome our
new alien overlords at the talk with
Richard and I about whether he would -
is jamun senior researcher with the
what-if team Jay how are you are you
doing good when you're not busy sucking
up if you will to the alien overlords
yeah my fantasy is all I have so why did
this come up as a as a what-if video
idea well you know it's it's trying to
sort of expand on that idea or try to
get people to think outside of the box
that everything about this universe is
about humans we always use us as the
barometer let's measure everything out
there against our accomplishments right
so but we wanted to put a spin on that
and sort of put the question out there
well what if we're somebodies hiccup
what what if were the kind of the stench
they can't quite get out of the room so
they've just sort of set it off to the
side and we're just kind of spinning
around doing our thing well it speaks to
like I mean the one thing about the zoo
analogy it's quite powerful and this be
hard to find a person that's never been
to a zoo or doesn't know what a zoo is
there's a couple of things that are
implied from that right I'm in a zoo in
the end is us who are better or let's
say the highest on the food chain going
to look at and amuse ourselves let's say
with the lesser species right and
they're and they're caged and they're
you know they have some freedom but
they're not free if we extrapolate that
concept and apply to this there's a lot
of people would be like wait a sec that
that's a terrifying thought because that
definitely puts us lower on the food
chain if you will of other species out
there how does the idea for you guys
putting this together address that idea
that you know we're just I don't want to
say sheep and you know animals but in
that and that's an area we are mm-hmm
if we're in a Galactic Zoo
you know if that's the case because if
you look at it by the numbers we still
have explored less than or we know about
even zero percent of what's out there so
not one percent not tubers not even
we're not even but we're at zero yeah
yeah we're not even a blink on that
chart for for what's out there so it's
that idea it's like okay there certainly
must be something out there that's kind
of checking in on us but what would we
do if we knew it was happening what
would we do if some people thought it
was happening and others didn't fall in
line with that train of thought and what
we what would be need for the proof how
do we prove somebody is watching us if
we did actually know that that was going
on what does that do to society in
general right you know just to society
changed as a religion gets thrown out
the window if we think there's somebody
up there looking at us do we up the
efforts to try and reach out to them do
we start to even look at ourselves in
words and wonder why they're not trying
to contact us what are we doing wrong
that they want to avoid well it's
interesting because we I mean that is
kind of the basis of religion is that
there we there is somebody watching
weather watchers are the creator the
watchers are the creators going back to
whether it's on Mount Olympus or in
heaven or whatever you but let's try
this from another perspective because we
we often either default to one of those
two possibilities the god concept or the
alien concept but a third possibility
here could be a lie west world for
instance right and it I love if you if
you watch West world and it's not a
spoiler to say that they're literally
standing over a miniature version of the
park and watching their children there's
their creations operate and obviously
intervening when necessary etc and it to
me it's a really strong visual of the
idea of the Galactic Zoo what if that's
the case what if it's what if we are AI
and there whoever created us is watching
us from a
from a different perspective so we've
sort of taken the singularity and jumped
it into space vo so they're so they're
coming down with that well then then you
start to get into if we are the the AI
well good for us look how much we've
accomplished is just as just the AI feel
like if I was in space watching humanity
I'd be freaked out by a lot of what we
do and entertain or a lot of it depends
on the soundtrack yes that's a good good
soundtrack can make all the difference
Jay thanks so much for being here and
after the break we're gonna be joined by
someone we're very very lucky to have on
the podcast
Douglas vaca who is one of Earth's
leading figures in our search for
extraterrestrials who may or may not
also be our galactic zookeepers that's
coming up since his time in high school
back in rural Minnesota Douglas Vikash
has attempted to communicate with
interstellar beings as an American
astrobiologist researcher and
psychologist he spent some time at SETI
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
specifically working on interstellar
message composition now as founder and
president of Medi messaging
extraterrestrial intelligence he
continues his quest along with other
scientists and astrobiologists to
communicate with interstellar life
welcome back to what if discussed
today's question what if we're living in
a galactic Zoo and joining us to discuss
further as astrobiologists SETI
researcher and founder of the
organization Metis or messaging
extraterrestrial intelligence
Douglas package hello there how are you
very well thanks glad to join you today
well we're really glad that you've
joined us and you are an amazing guest
to be talking to about about this
subject we've got a lot to dive into
with you but right off the top let's
pose that question to you because this
is your life's work so what if we were
living in a galactic Zoo well you know
if we're living in the Galactic Zoo it
could seem pretty quiet
I mean imagine that you and I went out
to the zoo and we're looking at a bunch
of animals we might we would know
they're there and you know they would be
looking at us and know we're here but
there wouldn't be a lot of conversation
going on you know if we're looking at a
bunch of zebras and they're just talking
to one another and kind of doing their
zebra thing we would tend to move on to
the gazelles but what we really are
wondering when we asked that question
about the Galactic Zoo if there's
anything about that scenario that we
could tweak a little bit that could
actually lead to interspecies
communication because that's the whole
goal of SETI the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence which has
been going on for over half century and
the more recent project Mattie messaging
extraterrestrial intelligence where we
actively send messages of our own trying
to make contact so I would I would say
the most obvious follow-up question and
this is maybe my personal opinion that
if we were to conclude that we are
living in a galactic Zoo my next
question would be who are the zoo
keepers and I'm sure that would come up
a lot in your work how would you answer
that question the civilizations that we
want to make contact with our
civilizations that have been around a
long long time
we humans have had radio technology for
about a century but if that's the norm
across the universe then we're not going
to be around at the same time as another
civilization so our universe has existed
for a bit over thirteen billion years in
a universe that old if two civilizations
each lasts a hundred years one pops up
at one point one pops up at another
point what's the likelihood they're
going to overlap in the course of that
thirteen billion years it's virtually
zero so the only way we'll make contact
is if the other civilization is much
older than we are and so in that case
they would be like the Galactic
zookeeper the ones who have been around
perhaps they have been observing us but
they're simply out there listening and
and observing us almost like we observe
animals in a zoo and so at first glance
that seems like it's a pretty
pessimistic scenario for us making
contact if they already know we're here
if they're already watching us then it's
and they've decided not to be sending us
messages because we've been looking at a
lot of stars then it sounds like we're
in this zoo or were the caged animals
and they're observing from afar but
that's it and we can never know that
they're there but again let's imagine
that we all go to the zoo and we're like
the Galactic zoo keepers where the zoo
keepers but all of a sudden instead of
that zebra just looking around and you
know chumming around with other zebras
it turns toward us
looks us straight in the eye and starts
counting out a series of numbers with
it's tough I mean that would establish a
radically different relationship between
us and the zebra and you can bet I'm not
going to go down and check out the
hyenas at this point I'm gonna really
try to establish some relationship and
really understand better what in the
world is going on in the mind of the
zebra that it's no longer content just
to be in its own environment but it's
reaching out to me and so that's the
hope of Metis messaging extraterrestrial
intelligence that instead of just
passively waiting for the signals to
come in we reach out to them to let them
know we want to make first contact and
you know it may be that some
civilizations out there are sending us
signals we just haven't come across them
yet but at least for some civilizations
maybe they require us to take the
initiative so in a sense adding many to
the mix of strategies is growing up as
an interstellar civilization that
we're adding another way that we might
make contact for any civilizations out
there that are looking at us like
animals in the Galactic Zoo but animals
that if they start speaking back might
be interesting enough to engage in
conversation that that's a really
interesting way to frame the question
and so let's assume we are the animals
in a Galactic Zoo and there is an
another type of being watching us and
observing us let's talk about making
contact because I know you say that time
scale is the the biggest obstacle in
terms of sending and receiving Anna plot
a reply you said before that in a
best-case scenario it takes around four
to five years for a message to get there
and get back and that's that's assuming
that we're messaging potential alien
life in a very closed star system but
let's say we can get that message out
there I know that you've said previously
that Trappist one is one of your
favorite targets for you and your
colleagues at messaging extraterrestrial
intelligence tell us a little bit about
Trappist wall on and why you think it
could be the home of our galactic
zookeepers what Trappist is a wonderful
star system and first of all it is
closed on a galactic scale remember the
our our a Milky Way galaxy is a hundred
thousand light-years across so takes a
hundred thousand years from light to go
from one end of the galaxy to the other
so that's a incredibly big distance on
that galactic scale Trappist is right in
our own backyard it's only 40
light-years away at but within this
single star system there are at least
seven planets and three of them are at
just the right distance from the star to
be potentially habitable and so when we
try to determine whether a planet that's
orbiting another star is habitable we
look at how far away from the star it is
and what it's made up of is it a rocky
sort of planet like the earth or is it
more of a gaseous planet like Jupiter or
Saturn and so there are
three planets orbitting Trappist one
that are rocky source and planets like
our earth so they would have the kind of
chemicals kind of elements that would be
necessary to support complex biologies
but just as importantly they are not so
close to the star that they're going to
be scorched by the fire of the star
they're not so far out away from that
star that they're going to be frozen but
they're in what we call the Goldilocks
summer where it's not too hot not too
cold but just right to support liquid
water so again sort of taking this let's
say to the next level there's plenty of
fiction movies etc where you know the
concept of humanity living in a world
that they believe is quote-unquote real
and ultimately discovering you know
whether you take something like the maze
hunter or even the Truman Show or
whatever it is that there's actually
somebody watching observing and again
you would take that as somebody who's
watching and observing for a reason that
is a matrix a matrix and you know an
experiment if you will but what you can
also sort of extrapolate from that idea
potentially is that the watcher is also
the creator and that doesn't necessarily
mean that you made it that it is the
case but I've got to believe that that's
come up before when people are talking
about the Galactic Zoo concept that in
fact if somebody is watching it that
they were more more than likely part of
our prehistory how do you where do you
fall on that well it that certainly
makes sense when you think about the
zoos that we have created here on earth
so it intuitively makes sense the big
difference though when we are talking
about the possibility of being on a
galactic scale Zoo is that it really
does take a quite a bit of energy to
travel between the stars I mean I'm not
saying that's impossible but it's
certainly a lot easier to communicate
with radio and laser signals they can
you we can send signals at interstellar
distances very rapidly very cheaply as
compared to being a pretty owners
process to travel between the stars and
really if they have already come here up
well we certainly haven't seen evidence
there are some people who think UFOs are
an unidentified aerial phenomenon her
evidence of aliens I haven't seen
anything that's convinced me I mean no
one's brought me any any material object
that has not been already created here
on earth so I I don't see credibility in
the claims that the aliens have already
come in so it's it's certainly I guess a
possibility that earth could have been
seeded from life in space maybe it is a
an element of a lot of science fiction
stories where you know the aliens came
here's to you dearth and now they'll
they'll go away for a number of years
and see what has developed but typically
it's it's a an interesting mindset
within the SETI and métis communities
that we attempt to be really quite
open-minded about new possibilities
always exploring alternative ways of
making contact but also as much as we
can be grounded in the constraints of
science as we know them right now so you
know I I can't rule out the possibility
that if there are galactic zookeepers
that you know they populated our world
all I would say is that if they did it
it seems like they went back pretty
early in the process because what
evolutionary biology has shown us is
that there is a is clear evidence of the
complexification and diversification of
life from the most primordial life
single-celled life over three billion
years ago so there's no evidence of any
sort of interventional
so if the aliens seeded life they had to
be pretty early off so here's a
curveball of a question though I think
on this topic most questions are our
curveballs that obviously very
speculative and hypothetical but if we
are at a galactic Zoo and the Watchers
have ability to make contact with us but
they've not yet made contact they've
chosen to not yet make contact what do
you think could prompt them to make
contact one of my favorite depictions of
this idea in science fiction is from the
film Star Trek first contact and in that
film a character named dr. Zefram
Cochrane invents warp drive uses warp
drive on earth for the first time and
that is the impetus for aliens in this
case I believe it's um it's Vulcans to
make contact with Earthlings to make
first contact so what do you think could
prompt our galactic zookeepers to make
contact if they're out there and
watching us well following up that Star
Trek universe first contact scenarios
one reason that it's okay to break the
prime directive so the prime directive
is don't interfere with a less
technologically advanced civilization
unless and then unless what
unless they already have warp drive in
which case are they're on the verge of
going out into the universe and
exploring but we've also seen a number
of cases in other episodes especially in
the original series with Kirk kind of
violating the prime directive frequently
the idea that that maybe this is a
civilization on the brink of its
annihilation and providing a little bit
of information could help avoid that now
again some strict definition of the
prime directive I don't know that you're
going to get everyone at the Federation
to agree that it's appropriate to break
the prime directive but their individual
starship captains that will do that and
so I think it depends to how you would
interpret that sense of
when do you let another civilization
know that there is life out there if
you're the Galactic zookeeper I have to
say my real fear might might when I the
thing that keeps me up at night it gives
me nightmares is that the aliens in fact
are like hyper intelligent cats just
like my own cat he knows that I'm here
he really just doesn't care and so in
that case the question is what could I
possibly do that would intrigue him
enough get him interested enough in
something like me that's not that
interesting in his world and similarly
for the Galactic zookeepers well we're
just you know other animals in a zoo
what's interesting in that the prompt to
reply so like with my cat it's the
question is what's the analog of an
interstellar yard something intriguing
enough to make them want to know a
little bit more and I think sometimes
it's really intimidating to imagine
contact with the civils maybe a million
years more that's I mean what do we have
to teach that if they are really the
Masters of this galactic Zoo they know
science a million years beyond our
science what do we have to teach them
and I think the key then is to really
put ourselves in the proper perspective
the nasty what is it that a civilization
so we young on the Galactic scale could
teach someone so old and so our natural
emphasis when we meet a stranger is to
show how strong and wise and powerful we
are admittedly we're not going to be any
of those things compared to a million
year old civilization maybe instead we
should emphasize just the opposite what
perspective can we bring as a
civilization that really is uncertain
about our future are we going to survive
global warming are we going to survive
the threat of nuclear war how do we as
individual get through our lives knowing
that someday inevitably we're going to
die so I think it's these
fears these insecurities related to our
own finitude that may actually be the
most interesting things things that a
civilization far in advance of us may
have really forgotten I mean if they're
stable enough to have been searching for
a million years they're likely going to
continue to exist another million years
but for us that's not at all the case
and so I think what we can really teach
them is almost it's a it's a chance to
let them remember their own history a
history they've long since forgotten but
now that they can see living itself in
front of them through us that is a
deeply interesting way to wait way to
put it like they're looking into the
past yeah I think so I think so and you
know I think that's the big thing that
we really have to gain you know there's
some who would say oh it's dangerous to
transmit to the aliens they're gonna
come to earth and annihilate us or you
know maybe they will send us all of the
secrets up to overcoming all of the
conflicts we have here on earth
I think when we imagine aliens it's
natural to project our our greatest
fears and our deepest desires out there
realistically I don't think we'll get
either of those but maybe what we most
get is a chance to hold a mirror up to
ourselves and so in the same way I think
we can hold a mirror up to the aliens
well Douglas I'm pretty sure I speak for
both Richard and I when I say that if
aliens if our watchers in this galactic
zoo are akin to hyper intelligent cats I
hope they don't treat us like a ball of
string or yarn and just add us around
the living room of the universe that's
right that's right but the trick is
maybe we can tie something onto the end
of that but put something in the middle
of that ball of yarn that they'll at
least bring the connection back to us I
see a meme developing Douglas thank you
so much for chatting with us this has
been really really really really
fascinating as a discussion we
appreciate your time and wanted to ask
you how should people find you and Medi
messaging
extraterrestrial intelligence online if
they want to read more about what you
and your colleagues do just come to our
website wwm a DME TI org Douglas package
thanks for joining us
take care more of what if discussed
coming up after this
hey everyone Richard here we are having
so much fun making the show for you we
wanted to find the most knowledgeable
experts and people to interview for this
podcast we hope you're enjoying it so
far we're currently creating the next
season of what if discussed and we'd
really appreciate your help if you like
what we do here support us on patreon by
contributing to our show you will get
exclusive access to our behind the
scenes episodes you'll get your what-if
questions answered and you'll receive a
personal voice message head over to our
show notes and sign up to become part of
our patreon community this is what if
discussed here our Richard Garner and
Teddy Wilson again another fascinating
discussion as you would I guess hope to
expect when you're tuning into an
episode of what if discussed but
especially when that's that episode is
called what if we are living in a glass
do and you have again arguably the most
knowledgeable person about this subject
matter on the earth or in the area code
is on the short list that's a short list
as somebody like Douglas vac watch and
if you haven't had a chance by the way
and maybe we'll we'll send some links
out on the Facebook or in the what if
discussed group but there's a lot of
great TED talks that he's done on this
subject matter and actually most of our
guests have those types of things but
he's a really fascinating dude I mean
one of the first things that I took away
from that is just again somebody that's
been at this for a long time who is so
passionate about the the you know the
search the exploration that sounds like
somebody who he could he could be
teaching a grade seven chemistry class
and addressing NASA right like he's he's
somebody it's very accessible in a lot
of ways but very very passionate about
the idea of
us being essentially animals in an
intergalactic Zoo not willing to
necessarily make absolute conclusions
one way or the other but it was a pretty
open-minded and cool guest for lack of a
better way to say it yeah and I mean I
was really intrigued by his talking
about the difference between Metis
messaging extraterrestrial intelligence
and of course the organization that more
people probably know of and have have
preconceived notions of and that is SETI
the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence I found his kind of
discussion of the difference between
those two very interesting he also
brought us some ideas that I haven't up
to this point thought of and
specifically he talked about you know
what could uh what could an advanced
alien civilization tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands millions of years
ahead of us in terms of evolution learn
from us and he I was very interested in
the way he talked about our
vulnerability or our fear of death and
that aliens could learn from that and
then it would almost be novel to them
I'd never thought about it in those
terms I've only thought about it to be
honest in the in terms of benevolent or
mom that malevolent are they coming to
help us or even just to observe us or
are they coming to kill us but he put
some different he put some different
angles on that on that kind of notion
and I really like that and that's it
like almost like we're more a curiosity
yeah it like almost like well the cat
example cat just doesn't care the only
reason you're bringing up a cat in this
context is to demonstrate aloofness
right basically man don't care one way
or the other are you feeding me or not
yeah like and and it was interesting
because he referenced his cat but in
that regard some people and because
medhi and I don't know this I apologize
I think I'll I'll google this later but
I would assume because Nettie's a
relatively newer organization versus
SETI which as we know has been around
for a few decades now and Metis again
was kind of SETI 2.0 well wait a sec
we've been listening for X amount of
decades perhaps maybe we should be
sending a message instead or in parallel
with listening we should always also be
sending a message
Douglas vac Koch is logic for that is to
almost let a super advanced species know
that hey we're here like where is zebra
example that if if we were walking by
zebras in a zoo and a zebra turn around
start talking to you would be like hey
everybody stop we've got to get these
zebras out of here they're conscious
beings like more than we thought
right and his his logic is that's kind
of why we'd be doing the many sort of
methodology but I assume that's also
when Stephen Hawking came out with
sounding the alarm around the idea of
sending messages out his his position on
what that was that's a bad idea because
if we send a message out to somebody who
doesn't know and they are malevolent and
they and there's like hey thanks for
helping us we were looking for somebody
to conquer and you just basically said
hey here we are I personally don't
believe that but you know somebody like
Hawking of Hawking sort of intelligence
to the seemed you got to you got to
respect it I guess and I mean the other
thing is you know we think in terms of
us being not as advanced and our
potential Galactic zookeepers or
Watchers being more advanced but it
could also be that you know we're
sending a message that they can't
properly interpret it's not just about
whether or not they're more advanced
than us it has to do with whether they
speak the types of language that we're
sending out you know the Voyager space
probes obviously famously include the
golden record right which has
information about earth and about us as
a human species but just because a
receiving alien life-form
is
more advanced than us doesn't mean that
they would properly interpret that
message you know they might not be able
to interpret it because they're so far
advanced that they've forgotten how to
communicate in the way that we do
currently or there are there are any
sort of number of of options or of
eventualities right but I'm intrigued by
that you know that we're already sending
messages out and that MIDI is obviously
furthering that I also thought it was
interesting talking to him about
Trappist one and I asked him about that
star system in particular because in the
last few years it's the Alpha Centauri
system that's really grasped a lot of
the headlines in terms of people like us
who are curious about the search for
extraterrestrial life and that is cos
Alpha Centauri is the closest star to us
and it's also where they've recently
discovered the planet Proxima B which
they say is the most earth-like planet
that we have found as an exoplanet up to
this point so I wanted to ask him about
that one in particular because I had
heard him speak about it in previous
interviews and I liked what he had to
say about Trappist 1 and it seems that
that should certainly be a focus of our
of our search for um for
extraterrestrial life it's interesting
because he also said and it's not
something we're not aware of but when
somebody repeats and reminds you of the
fact that yes we've like how young we
are right he said radio frequency thing
for a hundred years yeah
now here you're talking about Trappist 1
and all these other galaxies that we've
obviously discovered in a very short
period of time through an incredible
advancement in technology of telescopes
of of everything else and yet as we're
as we're searching the Stars and talking
about different galaxies and all these
things we're babies yeah like we're
little infants probably relative to what
other species would be in a gal in a
universe of 14 billion so years and
that's always the other thing that we
need to probably be reminded of that
this we're just beginning this search
right like it really is but it's it's
happening faster and faster and faster
if if a hundred years ago we didn't have
radio signals and now we're talking
about you know stuff like the the web
Ellis cope going out there that can see
and I don't know what yeah Jesus Webb
tells us the James Webb telescope this
is this is happening at an exponential
rate we talk about the exponential rate
of Technology and create and change much
law but in Moore's law in this
particular context this search is is is
on fast-forward yeah
well I'm certainly endlessly intrigued
by the the possibility of living in a
galactic Zoo I just hope our zookeepers
our watchers are of the benevolent
variety couldn't put it better myself
thank you so much for being a part of
this episode and for joining us and
we'll catch you on the next what if
discuss
[Music]